thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
I am freezing oh
it was like 13 degrees when I woke up
and it was still dark out when I was
driving up here and there were
definitely some patches of black ice
that I hit where I was just kind of
sliding around a little bit and as you
guys know I don't have 4x4 so
I was driving very slow and it is
freaking cold oh my God I'm shaking oh
and I get to shower today I'm really
excited about that it's been a while
which is silly it doesn't have to be
wild because there's a shower at camp
Curry I just haven't gotten around to it
but today's the day I'm gonna do it
these are my down mittens I would die
without them I'm praying that I have
enough power in my house battery to make
coffee because this morning
I woke up turn on the light and then
tried to turn on the heater and then
everything shut off so my house battery
completely died
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
this is my
what number is this maybe Fourth Man
and you just bought another one right oh
yeah it's gonna be a sweet one he always
has so many unique things like this
little hidden mirror here
it would probably be hard to be
one-handed
Flip It Up
these I love it so cool lights
fancy yeah those little features to
really do it for me you know my new man
that I'm making right now has like a
full wall mirror no way like like it
makes it feel bigger
I guess you can see what you look like
more so it feels more like
more like a home for sure
so yesterday I went around Yosemite all
day which is amazing but my battery's
dead and I'm going to charge it but it's
not charging
um so I looked online and it looks like
maybe I need to replace a fuse
oh it's working
all right so um that did not work I
tried to kind of pry it open a little
bit but I think it's just gonna snap the
plastic and then it will really be
unusable so I think so the issue right
now is that one of the screws is really
lodged in there it will not budge it
actually broke the tip of my Leatherman
and at this point it's kind of threaded
so if I can get that screw out then I
can try the fuse and if the fuse is the
incorrect one then I'll just have to
wait until I pass through a city again
maybe I'll go for a hike instead or
maybe I'll actually do some of the work
I'm supposed to do I still didn't get
this screw out but I was able to pop off
The Fuse cover and pull them out and the
40 amp is the one we have a replacement
for but it's intact
five is burnt
so Mike had the idea to pull a fuse out
from my house battery and there's one
five would you say large size yeah so
pirated it from the house battery and
gonna see if it works
try this one
[Music]
that's not very cool
because it looks like you're like
Wheeling
[Music]
all right
thank you
[Music]
so this is my friend Mike's rig is
Alexis totally souped up
so many luxury things attached to this
vehicle
hello hey hey
yeah
try that thing out
[Music]
yeah they take up such little room
two ways of life
[Music]
foreign
just got back from getting pizza at the
curry Pavilion the pizza Pavilion So
Good by the way if you've never been and
just realized that the five fuse amp
that took out of the house battery to
run the power or the I'm so cold I can't
talk to run the e-bike uh is actually
really important because now my heater
won't work because
so I gotta take the fuse out of the
battery again and put it back to the
house battery so that I could use my
heater and then do it again in the
morning anyway it's been a day it's been
a really good day it's been a day okay
[Music]
take over me
if only foreign
[Music]